healthcare is something that is more i
would say
closer to the pure goods than than most
technical things very hard to use a
medical device to hurt somebody unless
you know you're doing a mistake
as an engineer welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community-driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
building medical devices is difficult
and it's different from traditional sas
startups that we usually talk to meet
shai poliker the ceo of medex
accelerator lp
in the last 20 years chai has been
leading the development clinical
validation and commercialization of
innovative medical devices for various
indications such as heart failure
metabolic and gastrointestinal diseases
shy holds an electrical engineering
degree from the technion
israel institute of technology and an
mba from columbia university
he is an inventor of 40 issued patents
and he currently
serves as a ceo of medics accelerator a
leading medical device and digital
health incubator
a partnership of boston scientific
medics ventures
intellectual ventures and the sheba
medical center okay
shai are you ready to get started yes
all right shai poliker welcome to 20
minute leaders how are you today
very good happy to be here with you
i'm really excited to be here with you
because a lot of the guests that i have
on the show
um a lot of them are coming from the
traditional startup world
a lot of sas products um that
you know have a little bit of a
different i believe life cycle than
a lot of the companies that you're
working with at medics accelerator lp
and what i'm really curious to hear both
about your own journey but also about
the medical devices space
and some of the the interesting you know
life cycle for companies there how you
work with them you're a part of many
many companies that you're
that you're supporting throughout the
years and so even before we get to that
cha how do you how do you find yourself
into into this space you know from the
technion in electrical engineering and
then
mba from columbia university what is it
about you know
medical devices and health tech that
really got you hooked
uh well so i'm um i've been in
engineering for
quite a from very early from my
very early days uh already from an army
service and
you know in one of those technical
intelligence
units and i think what what attracted me
to medical devices
is pretty typical is the fact that you
are able to
actually you know heal people or
diagnose people and do something
very immediate uh good to the world
rather than just you know a new
generation to a cell phone
or a software or some you know some
cyber uh some cyber
software would where all of those you
know are very important and help us
both in entertainment and you know and
defense
but healthcare is something that is more
i would say closer to the pure goods
than than
most technical things very hard to use a
medical device to hurt somebody unless
you know you're doing a mistake
as an engineer right so you finished the
teflon i believe in
around 95 and you finish your mba in
at what point do you know as an engineer
that
your mission is to improve people's
lives through medical devices and health
tech when
when does it become you know really
clear intrinsically to you
that this is what you want to dedicate
your time to
it was it was probably during my last
year of the
technion i've done a couple of uh you
know as an engineer you have to do an
electrical engineering project
both of them were in the area of signal
processing machine learning
you know of biological data and this
really was very exciting to me
so i i knew then that this is this is
what i want to do in the
you know at least in the next 10 years
wow okay so i want to talk about about
medical health tech devices and medics
accelerator and to do that
can you give me a little bit of a brief
rundown what is medics accelerator lp
you're the ceo of it what what is this
group trying to do
so we are part of the um government
incubator program which means that we
are from one hand
a private partnership of investors like
uh tip your typical vc
uh but on the other hand for every
investment we are doing we are getting a
grant from the israeli innovation
authority
and the idea here is to promote early
stage high risk
investments in the super early stage um
which where it's harder to get the
more um experienced strategic investors
to get involved
so you know companies the large
companies like metronic boston
scientific
uh jnj these are
they prefer typically to invest in an
early stage of the venture
take less risk and the the
incubator program really encourages them
by reducing the financial risk
encourages them to to get in in the you
know
at ground uh at ground zero so you are
getting
um kind of a leverage from the
government that reduces your
your risk um simply by uh by a grant
that the company needs to return only
when they are successful so it's a
really
low risk situation uh so all of our
investments are done
under that framework
so i so that's actually you know
obviously very very rewarding for
entrepreneurs and a great you know great
reason to to be a part of this program
if you compare this to the traditional
tech scene
and the traditional startup before you
mention some of those also important
industries like cyber security and
social
and and the traditional ai as sas
products
why is it more challenging you know in
your space
for an early stage startup why why is it
more challenging
one of the things that is and i think
maybe the main
the main thing that makes a med tech
more difficult as a
in the early stages that you need a
multiple elements a complete that are
almost completely independent from each
other to be successful so for example if
you are if you are starting as a
like a consumer software company you
need a group of very good
programmers uh to get started and to get
to
and to get to market here you would need
a for successful medical device you
would need the technology
sometimes multi-disciplinary technology
and then you would also need regulatory
experts clinical trial experts sometimes
animal research or basic research
people so there are you know this kind
of
we like to think about this as a stool
that you are preparing
there are a lot of elements that you
need to put into the pots in order to
make a successful
dish and if you want to create a
a real a team you know very high
highly experienced good people
you would need a lot of money to get
started so it's very hard to do
something like that when
the idea is really still very risky you
don't know in three months or in six
months maybe your proof of concept will
fail
so it's very hard to put all that
together and when you have an incubator
that can share those resources and can
do uh
you know those group of experienced
people in all of those fields
can share their time with some
additional um
risk reduction from the government then
you you kind of get uh
to to jump over that that chasm and
and get started even though
um you know without needing
you know millions of dollars to get
started
so is this incubator serving as some
sort of figure that is a domain
expert in in the life cycle of an early
stage
company in the health tech and medical
devices space and you're and you're
helping bridge that you know that gap
between the things that
you know really later stage companies
can do that early stage companies don't
really have the knowledge of how to do
is that what i'm getting at
it's it's not usually when you when you
meet the entrepreneurs that come to us
to the enter
the the incubator they would be very
very good
experts on their technology typically
or some specific clinical area but in
order to be successful they would need
the entire
set of of elements and uh
and dimensions and even if one of them
will not be
in place they will have much lower
chance to succeed
so this is where the incubator really
helps them
for example if you have a great
technology with a strong clinical need
but you don't know how to put together a
good regulatory strategy
or a good reimbursement strategy you
know who's going to pay for that
for that product you're going to be in
trouble very soon you may
actually develop the wrong product
because all of those elements
needs to kind of fit together for
successful medical
device so it's not that the
entrepreneurs are
not knowledgeable they are simply they
are knowledgeable
in in a restricted area in where they
made their invention
and where we help them is that we add
those missing elements
to the level that these are needed uh
to to help to supplement what what they
already know
so it sounds to me that while for
traditional entrepreneurs in
the traditional industries that we spoke
about earlier while they have a lot of
resources around them you know they have
a lot of great advisors and investors
and even
you know sometimes their programmers
understand the industry just as well as
they do
in in your case you're talking to
entrepreneurs that while they're domain
experts
in their own inventions then they really
are experts
there it's much harder for them to
understand the complexity behind
the regulatory the reimbursement which i
still don't even know what that is
and that's where you come in and you can
assist them by saying listen we've seen
a lot of this these are the places this
is where you need to spend your time on
and we're here to help you to give you
that
input right yes exactly exactly i mean
uh you it's almost impossible to be
knowledgeable in
all of those elements just by one person
or you know or a group of two founders
so you really need like a group of five
six experienced people and the engineer
will not be successful without the
clinician and the clinician will not be
successful without the engineer
and both of them need though this uh
regulatory fda
if you will expert or when i say
reimbursement this means that
you know the insurance the the strategy
towards the insurance insurance company
what kind of code are you going to use
to be to this for this to get paid by
the hospital or by the clinic
and so when you're bringing on um
when you're bringing on entrepreneurs
and inventions and i spoke with inval
earlier in a different episode and she
mentioned how competitive it is and how
you know how how intense the the from
your perspective is to to
find the right people to bring on board
into the incubation
what happens then how does the
incubation actually take place from the
moment you bring the entrepreneurs
in until the moment where where where
you're sort of
terminating the relationship or or
continuing it in a lower capacity than
before
so uh i think first of all there this is
one
another big difference between an
incubator and a
like a typical vc investor is that we
are highly involved in the day-to-day
life of the companies the companies
actually reside in our offices
and we don't just uh help the companies
or manage them or and
or sit on the board although all of
these three things are correct we
actually we like to say that we work in
the companies
we feel uh we almost feel like specific
positions in the companies our team
my my incubator team um to to
uh you know day in day out we spread our
our time between those various companies
and this actually starts
before the company even starts we
usually do that already in the due
diligence process
so we will see the the the founders
and we look at all these aspects we'll
ask them questions and we'll see very
very quickly
what are the missing parts and we'll
start making suggestions and we'll start
to look at their patents and see well
maybe our patent experts can help you
here
you know what is your regulatory
strategy then yeah did you think about
this and that
and over a course of a few months
when we do our due diligence is actually
what we call a constructive due
diligence process we already can start
to solve some of those
problems uh before they even get into
the
into the incubator sometimes after the
the due diligence the project looks
completely different than what it looked
what it looked like when the
entrepreneurs actually came to see us
for the first time
and then the second thing you said was
not exactly
um how it works uh
with some of the companies that graduate
our program is two years
they actually leave the the the
incubator
moved to a separate offices then we just
remain a board members but also some of
them
remain with us we help them raise the
foreign investments
sometimes this is coming from our own
partners sometimes from other investors
we are very involved in the fundraising
process we
we actually lead that in in most cases
and then
uh the the groups if it makes sense to
them if it
if it is worthwhile for them they would
stay for another year or two
in this capital efficient mode before
they actually
move out and we even um recently we even
exited in one company in our first
investment was actually
already our first exit so that also
happened so they move away
it's like leaving the incubator and then
we are not very involved
i love it and so just to give a flavor a
little bit of
of you know the types of problems that
you get to deal with and i say you get
to deal with because it sounds like it's
really a
you know it's a privilege to get to work
with entrepreneurs that are the main
experts in their inventions that are
literally going to to improve people's
lives can you give me some flavor as to
the types of problems that your
entrepreneurs are working on solving
and and how how does that translate then
to to the world around us
yeah what one of the things that we
really love is is
problems that you need multidisciplinary
science to solve them
the in in in med tech you call it
bioconvergence
so it's the it's where biology and
machine learning
engineering meet and
converge to provide the a solution
one company like that is a is a company
soon to graduate us
our incubator is called exero it's a
it's a company company in the surgical
space
um that is uh used for diagnosing
anastomotic leaks it's a complication
it's a very serious complication
after gastrointestinal surgery so
this is basically a sensor that is
resolvable
and is used to detect biological changes
after the procedure to make sure
that the healing is is okay or if there
is a complication starting then
you can intervene quickly and it's very
hard to tell uh
to do that today so in order to
create that sensor we would need
from one hand the material engineering
aspects the
metallurgic it's a bioresorbable metal
that serves as an electrodes and
eventually dissolves
from the other hand you need algorithm
this is a this is a device that works
is based on algorithms both heuristic
and machine learning
and you need the software behind it and
you need the electrical engineering
portion to create the wireless
communication and device that sits with
the patients and
and you know presents the data and all
that so it
this is one one example this is a
product that
was born out of an idea very basic idea
um um in
berlin hospital owned by the largest
health insurer in israel a cleat um
a surgeon and a material engineer
that came to us with a with an idea and
a patent
and we helped develop that to create a
proof of concept
then and then a full idea
and in the two years of the incubator
and in in the budget of eight hundred
thousand dollars they went through all
the way from
building the prototype testing in small
and large animals
and recently during corona times
completing
uh first in human trial in the first
five patients
getting um a designation from the fda
for this being a breakthrough technology
so a fast track
uh regulatory approval and all that and
uh so
um we're very happy with them all in all
it just sounds like you get to work on
really exciting problems you get to see
the companies from the ground up you
obviously have
are already seeing successes with it
which is which sounds to me on
in your eyes it's you know it's a bonus
to to the already very fulfilling work
that you get to do
i have a few fun questions for you not
related to medical if you're ready
yes all right so we'll start off
easy favorite subject in middle school
or high school
i don't i don't think i had any favorite
subject at that time
uh i would be i would risk and say
you know science physics but even that
was not very i was not a very um
a focused student in those times
unfortunately i i love
i love that answer just as much as a as
all the others
and one of your role models somebody
that inspires you
you know on a regular basis
well i'll uh you're you're looking for
one person but i'll give you
i'll give you two very different first
of all i have to say that
my my own team the incubator team uh the
people that i work with are people
are really that i i like and admire and
they are an inspiration
daily inspiration people like inval and
gal and
and norm and others uh it's really it's
really fun to work with them
and we i think we make a very good group
uh
on the investment side somebody that
that i you know
i try to learn from over the years is
is a person called charlie monger i
think is that is a
is pretty well known but his partner
warren buffett is more well-known
but is a person that brings a lot of
value and understanding and deep
deep understanding and and thinking into
the world of investments
wonderful and three words that you would
choose to describe yourself or if i were
to ask anybody who is shy polikel
who is he um that's a very very tough
question
because i i think it's the hardest one
yeah
different person to different uh
different people
uh so um
yeah very hard question i i'll take i'll
take a different person to different
people and i think that one of the
things that i've distilled from over 400
episodes now is this idea that you know
in leadership
works obviously you know in the army
we're being taught 360 degrees of
leadership
you do need to be different not in an
honest way but but in a really genuine
way
different to different people because at
the end as a leader you're a leader
wherever you go
and i'm sure that in your position you
know a lot of people
are you know are looking up at the way
that and they look up to you as well as
as some sort of a role model or as
inspiration as as you help them on their
journey whether it's your team members
or with the companies you work with
and so i i love that answer just as much
if you're okay with that yeah yeah
absolutely we
definitely see our role as educators as
well
uh even for those that we that we would
not invest in eventually and this is
actually the vast majority of the of the
entrepreneurs we see
we like to think that we leave them they
leave us with
a little bit more than what they enter
the door with even if we
didn't get our money shy thank you very
very much toda continue making a
positive impact and helping
and helping entrepreneurs and inventors
and domain experts on their journey
um sounds like you're doing really
wonderful work thank you very much for
joining me i know how busy you are
so thank you for taking it thank you
michael it was a pleasure
take care